con base en lo que vimos en el vídeo
anterior tratemos de inferir algunas
reglas generales para saber cuántos
dígitos o cifras significativas tiene
cierta medida o cantidad podemos ver que
todos los dígitos diferentes a cero son
significativos incluyendo aquellos ceros
que se encuentran entre dígitos
diferentes de cero escribamos a estas
reglas una es
dígitos diferentes de 0
y 020 intermedios
ceros intermedios
significativos
con respecto a los ceros que no son
intermedios puede ser más confuso
identificarlos cuando hablamos de cifras
significativas siempre podemos descartar
los ceros iniciales o los que están a la
izquierda de el primer dígito diferente
de cero por ejemplo estos de aquí estos
de acá también y los demás no tienen así
que nuestra otra regla es ceros
iniciales ceros iniciales no
significativas
no son significativos lo que nos falta
definir es qué hacer con los ceros al
final o que están a la derecha del
último dígito que no es ser como por
ejemplo estos de aquí estos de aquí
estos
y nada más así que tenemos otras reglas
ceros
final
bueno si tienen punto decimal
un punto decimal
entonces son significativas
significativos pero cuando no tienen
punto decimal sin punto decimal esto se
vuelve en vivo claramente aquí tenemos
decimales en el número así que tomamos
en cuenta los ceros que están al final
oa la derecha de este dígito que es
diferente de cero ya que son parte de la
precisión aquí abajo tenemos un punto
decimal pero no tenemos ceros después de
ese aquí tenemos un punto decimal y
tenemos un cero después de ese punto
decimal aquí abajo no tenemos ceros a la
derecha y en este último caso este de
aquí donde te habíamos puesto un punto
para indicar que si tuviera ese punto no
habría ambigüedad y sabríamos que
tendría cinco dígitos significativos
pero como no tenía este punto esto es
ambiguo por lo tanto si es ambiguo
no se toman
en cuenta
y los ceros
al final hay una anotación especial para
especificar es exactamente el último
dígito significativa por ejemplo
supongamos que tenemos aquí 56 mil a
veces pueden encontrar una barrita
encima del 6 o a veces la verán por
debajo del 6 lo cual es muy útil porque
a lo mejor este 6 es nuestro último
dígito significativa
supongamos que este de aquí es nuestro
último dígito significativo nuestra
expresión quedaría con una barrita abajo
desde cero o arriba de este cero para
expresar que esta es la última cifra
significativa quizás se pueda medir con
precisión hasta las centenas y así es
como se quedarían nuestra cantidad de
expresada si ven algo así sabrán que
tiene tres cifras significativas aunque
no es muy común encontrar esta anotación
una forma más común es encontrar las
cifras significativas expresadas con
notación científica de hecho hay todo un
vídeo dedicado a explicar la notación
científica para escribir esto en
notación científica tendríamos 5.60 mis
cifras significativas por 10 elevado a
la 4 si esto los confunde los invito
para que vean este video sobre notación
científica
cuando se escribe usando notación
científica es muy sencillo ubicar cuáles
son los dígitos significativos que es
algo mucho más común que indicar el
último dígito con la barrita
y abajo así que es mejor usar la
notación científica espero que esto les
haya sido útil en los próximos vídeos
veremos más sobre por qué son
importantes las cifras significativas
especialmente cuando estamos haciendo
cálculos con varias mediciones